bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui
revient sur l'actualité de la semaine au Parlement
et cette semaine sur ce plateau nous accueillons
Pierre-Henri Dumont bonjour vous êtes députés
les républicains du pas decalais on va revoir
avec vous ce qui fait le débat au Parlement et à
la une cette semaine l'Assemblée nationale adopte
le projet de loi pour le plein emploi désormais
ma les bénéficiaires du RSA devront réaliser
15 Hees d'activité par semaine pour toucher leur
allocation le président de la République a dessiné
les contour de sa réforme de la Constitution
il est prêt à élargir le champ du référendum on
verra ce qu'en pensent les sénateurs qui jouent un
rôle crucial dans toute révision constitutionnelle
et puis le sujet des punaises de lis s'invite
à l'Assemblée nationale la France insoumise
dénonce la réaction tardive du Gouvernement sur
ce problème sanitaire qui gâche la vie de nombreux
Français l'assemblée nation a donc adopté mardi
4 octobre la loi elle a plutôt achevé le débat
sur la loi baptisée pour le plein emploi le texte
sera adopté lors d'un vote solennel le 10 octobre
prochain une mesure est au cœur de ce texte le
RSA sous conditions retour en séance avec Elsa
mondingava c'est le point le plus débattu du
projet de loi sur le plein emploi la réforme du
RSA le revenu de solidarité active le gouvernement
veut instaurer des contrepartie au versement de
cette allocation quand on dit solidarité active ça
veut dire activité et ce que nous faisons là c'est
au contraire investir pour faire en sorte que
l'accompagnement soit présent et que l'insertion
soit présente moi je ne me résous pas et je ne
me résoudrai jamais à ce que des hommes et des
femmes dans notre pays soient condamnés au RSA
pendant des dizaines des années et parfois même
des dizaines d'années et ce que nous faisons c'est
de mettre en place un parcours les bénéficiaires
devront signer un contrat d'engagement réciproque
un amendement proposé par la droite et voté par
la majorité impose 15 he d'activité hebdomadaire
une obligation dont pourront être exemptés les
parents isolés ou les allocataires porteurs de
handicap nous pensons que face au RSA il y a des
contreparties c'est 15h c'est quoi ce sont 15
he d'accompagnement de formation de stage à la
fois d'accompagnement professionnel et social
c'est pas l'un ou l'autre ce sont les deux la
gauche dénonce une mesure qui stigmatise les plus
précaires avec cette idée que au fond celles et
ceux qui sont RSA sont des feignants et qu'il faut
les mettre d'urgence au travail pour un revenu je
le rappelle un revenu qui est de 600 de 604 € le
texte prévoit aussi un nouveau régime de sanction
en cas de non respect des engagements en France
près d'1,9 millions de foyers sont à locataire du
RSA pieren dum si la loi voter donc mardi prochain
à l'Assemblée 15 he d'activité seront obligatoires
par semaine pour pouvoir toucher le RSA est-ce
que ce n'est pas tout de même stigmatisant à
l'encontre des bénéficiaires qui parfois n'ont
pas d'autre choix que d'être au RSA non mais
vous rigolez ce qui est stigmatisant smatisant
pardon c'est de faire de la fausse solidarité
comme vient de le proposer la gauche et la France
insoumise la fausse solidarité c'est quoi c'est
d'imaginer qu'on donne 607 € à des personnes et
qu'on s'en occupe plus moi je préfère que des gens
reprennent confiance en eux puissent avoir le pied
à l'étrier puissent reprendre une petite activité
il s'agit pas d'avoir du travail déguisé il
s'agit de les aider à remplir un CV une lettre de
motivation parfois leur donner une petite activité
qui serait par exemple d'accompagner des enfants
à l'écool le matin d'aider dans les collectivités
c'est au final redonner confiance à des personnes
qui sont très éloignées de l'emploi vous savez
il y a un il y a que un/ers des allocataires du
RSA qui à l'issue de 7 ans dans le RSA sortent
du dispositif est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal
non ce n'est absolument pas normal d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des très grands besoins
de main d'œuvre parfois il faut trouver le petit
moment déclencheur le moment déclencheur c'est
redonner confiance aux allocataires du RSA leur
dire qu'ils sont utiles à la société vous savez
dans la commune dont j'étais maire Marcon calisi
j'ai mis obligatoirement des heures de bénévola
dans le Pas de calé j'ai mis obligatoirement des
heures de bénévola pour toutes les personnes qui
bénéficient d'une aide de la commune on a eu
80 % de sorties positiv vers l'emploi ou la for
c'est donc des dispositifs qui fonctionnent
parce qu'on fait confiance aux gens et qu'on
leur redonne confiance en eux vous parlez de
besoin de main d'œuvre ça veut dire que vous
assumez que c'est bénéficiaires du RSA pourrait
répondre à ce besoin non c'est absolument pas ce
que j'ai dit je dis qu'il y a des besoins de main
d'œuvre et que donc on ne comprendrait pas qu'il y
ait d'un côté simplement un/ers des allocataire
du RSA qui sortent du RSA après 7 ans et que
de l'autre côté des entreprises n'arrivent pas à
recruter et que parfois il y a des personnes qui
sont très éloignées de l'emploi qui n'arrivent pas
à rentrer même dans des dispositifs d'insertion
et c'est pour ça qu'on qu'on souhaite une fois
plus leur remettre le pied à l'étrier ça s'agit
pas de prendre des allocataires du RSA pour
compléter les offres d'emploi manquantes il
s'agit simplement de les faire progresser petit
à petit vers le chemin de l'insertion du travail
les personnes qui sont très éloignées de l'emploi
elles rentreront peut-être grâce à ce dispositif
dans des dispositifs d'aide d'accompagnement
d'association d'insertion les personnes dans
les associations d'insertion arriveront peut-être
ensuite progressivement vers l'emploi et donc on
arrivera avec un cheminement positif qui permettra
de résoudre des problèmes d'emploid et surtout
surtout surtout de sortir de la précarité on ne
vit pas avec 607 € alors oui mais on comprend
bien la philosophie sur le papier mais est-ce que
notre système actuel de protection sociale encore
lourdement endetté a concrètement les moyens de
fournir ces 15 heures d'accompagnement c'est quand
même pas rien ça a été testé dans plusieurs
collectivités pas le même dispositif mais un
simili à ce dispositif ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
et je vous le dis là où ça a été testé il y a des
retours extrêmement positifs de la part évidemment
des départements qui portent cette mesure et qui
ont essayé cette mesure plutôt des départements de
droite d'ailleurs et puis surtout les allocataires
du RSA qui retrouvent un travail qui retrouvent
confiance en eux et qui sont capables de pouvoir
à nouveau peut-être se rendre utile la société et
rendre fi les enfants moi je je prends en mémoire
une personne qui était dans ma commune qui a donné
un coup de main lors d'une brocante pour sécuriser
la brocquante dans le dispositif que j'avais
mis en place et il m'a dit vous savez à l'époque
j'étais j'étais encore maire vous savez Monsieur
le Maire euh moi je pour la première fois mon fils
était fier il a dit regardez c'est mon papa en
passant devant lui donc il sécurisa la Brocan donc
c'est c'est également important N'oubliez jamais
ça alors cette mesure à l'Assemblée nationale elle
fait l'objet d'une alliance entre la majorité
présidentielle et les députés républicains
puisque c'est un amendement du député LR
philippe Juvin qui a été retenu finalement
entre l'ELR et la majorité présidentielle ce sont
les mêmes solutions qui sont proposées pour cette
question du chômage les républicains c'est le
parti des droits et des devoirs nous avions
toujours proposé dans nos programmes électoraux
c'est c'est dans mon programme aux élections
législatives par exemple la mise en place d'une
contrepartie au versement du RSA pas parce que
c'est quelque chose de nouveau mais c'est quelque
chose qui était imaginé depuis la création du RSA
mais qui n'avait jamais été réellement mise
en place donc la majorité a décidé de nous
rejoindre sur ce point ça avait été mis en place
par les sénateurs ça avait été proposé dans nos
différents programmes électorauuxx tant mieux
ça prouve que les républicains sont capables
de pouvoir faire des choses concrètes et si on
réussit à sortir des dizaines de milliers de
personnes du RSA ce sera une excellente nouvelle
pour ces person initialement ce sont bien les
sénateurs LR qui avaient instauré dans le texte
ces 15hures d'activité est-ce que vous vous êtes
concerté vous députés ici avec vos collègues
de la Chambre haute c'est c'est une proposition
du parti c'est une proposition des différents
candidats à l'élection présidentielles depuis de
nombreuses années des ça va plaire 15h d'activité
au sénateur c'est assez c'est assoupli c'est les
sénate estiment que vous avez trop assoupli le
dispositif car cette durée de 15 heur d'activité
par semaine pourrait être réduite en fonction du
profil individuel qu'est-ce que vous le dit on ta
la réalité c'est que nous avons exclu ça a été dit
dans votre reportage les personnes les parents
isolés qui ont des problèmes de garde d'enfants
les personnes en situation de handicap et si on
gardait la mesure initiale dans le texte telle qu'
était sortie de la commission c'estàd la volonté
des députés de la majorité associé aux voix de
la gauche et du rassemblement national qui s'est
complètement planqué durant ce débat où ils n'ont
pas pris position sur cette sur cette mesure et je
rappelle que les députés du rassemblement national
ont voté avec la nupes pour empêcher voter contre
cet amendement et pour ne pas avoir le les 15h
donc il est quand même passé alors la réalité
c'est quoi c'est que 15h peut-être que c'est pas
assez mais en tout cas c'est déjà un début et que
si on navait pas ce système de 15h tel qu'il a été
proposé par les députés et les républicains il n'
aurait rien eu du tout je préfère avoir 15h que
rien du tout et avec un minimum en effet ça peut
être dégressive selon le profil de la personne
mais la position initiale du gouvernement c'était
qu'il n'y avait vous pouvez faire zéro he dans
le contrat d'engagement nous que ce soit de la
formation que ce soit de l'accompagnement que
ce soit en effet un petit travail il y aura ces
15 heures qui sont mis en place et c'est déjà un
bon point alors cette semaine le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron a dessiné les contours
de sa prochaine révision de la Constitution il a
notamment défendu l'idée d'élargir les thèmes que
le Président de la République pourrait soumettre
à référendum alors qu'on pense à les sénateurs
qui auront leur mots à dire pour faire adopter
cette révision constitutionnelle un sujet de
Samia de chir c'est une promesse qui date de
son premier quinquena Emmanuel Macron veut
réformer la Constitution et notamment élargir
le champ du référendum très strictement encadré
par l'article 11 il ne peut aujourd'hui porter
que sur l'organisation des pouvoirs publics la
politique économique et sociale ou la ratification
de traités internationaux le président de la
République veut l'ouvrir à d'autres sujets il
existe encore des domaines importants pour la vie
de la nation qui échappent au champ de l'article
11 de notre Constitution et je souhaite que nous
puissions trouver collectivement les moyens de
mener à son terme ce chantier favorable à cet
élargissement la droite sénatoriale réclame un
engagement ferme du président pour l'organisation
d'un référendum sur l'immigration Emmanuel Macron
peut pas nous balader pendant des mois comme il
peut s'apprêter à le faire si parallèlement il
ne s'engage pas clairement à faire un référendum
et nous lui suggérons sur l'immigration mais les
centristes alliés de la droite au Sénat ne sont
pas favorables à l'élargissement du référendum
et encore moins sur l'immigration je serai oui ou
non à un paquet complet sur des questions qui sont
liées aux filières clandestines à la question de
du du du travail au régularisation et voulez le
faire comme ça par un paquet qu'on qu'on lance
au peuple en disant oui ou non la gauche elle
aussi opposée à tout référendum sur l'immigration
se montre sceptique sur les annonces d'Emmanuel
Macron le président s'est dit favorable à
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la Constitution
promesse déjà formulée le 8 mars dernier je ne
compte plus le nombre d'intervention d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la réforme constitutionnelle depuis
les 78 mois dans lequel dans lesquel il dirige
le pays donc voilà c'est une nouvelle annonce
qui s'inscrit dans une forme de procrastination
immigration interruption volontaire de grossesse
la réforme de la Constitution voulu par Emmanuel
Macron baler des sujets clivants des lignes rouges
pour la droite comme la gauche le président aura
bien du mal à faire adopter sa réforme par le
Parlement étape obligatoire pour changer la
constitution alors pieren les républicains veulent
élargir le champ du référendum à l'immigration
mais à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
les députés LR vous aurez une majorité pour
faire voter une telle mesure un élargissement un
référendum sur l'immigration quelle majorité vous
aurez écoutez on verra déjà la proposition
constitutionnelle qui est mise sur la table
par le Président de la République et par par le
gouvernement nous on a toujours été très clair
nous estimons que le champ de l'article 11 qui
ouvre le droit au référendum est beaucoup trop
limité et que donc il faut l'élargir à tous
les sujets l'immigration évidemment mais pas
que il faut qu'il y ait les sujets de société
qui puissent c'est aussi être r trranché vous
savez nous sommes une famille gouliste général
de Goul n'a jamais eu peur du peuple d'ailleurs
il est parti il a quitté le pouvoir à l'issue d'un
référendum qu'il avait perdu et donc nous estimons
que parfois quand les situations sont bloquées
il faut s'en remettre au peuple parce que il y a
des intérêts particuliers au niveau du Parlement
qui empêchent de trancher des sujets extrêmement
majeurs l'immigration évidemment premier chef on
comprend bien mais concrètement quelle question
vous pourriez poser au français vous allez
soumettre comme le disait votre collègue
du Sénat un paquet complet c'està- dire tout
le projet de loi immigration au français le
premier sujet c'est la réforme constitutionnelle
d'abord si on ne peut pas faire de de référendum
sur l'immigration s'il n'y a pas une réforme un
changement de l'article 11 de la Constitution
donc l'urgence le point le plus important c'est
d'abord de réformer la Constitution une fois que
cela est fait on verra les termes dans lesquels
la réforme constitutionnelle est proposée par le
gouvernement nous pourrions soit par un référendum
d'initiative partagé soit directement par une
décision du Sénat et de l'Assemblée nationale
présenter un référendum sur l'immigration avec
un sujet en particulier qui est la prédominance
du droit national dans cette matière migratoire
sur le droit européen parce qu'on l'a bien vu
une dernière décision de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne l'a malheureusement démontré
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus en possibilité de
d'imposer le pouvoir éégalien de savoir qui entre
qui se maintient qui doit partir du territoire
parce que un ensemble de textes qui sont pas des
textes européens mais qui sont des jurisprudences
des différentes cours de justice de l'Union
européenne empêche le pays notre pays de pouvoir
appliquer une politique migratoire qu'il désire
donc par référendum voulaz sortir des traités
européens sur les non nous voulons faire ce qu'on
appelle un optout c'est-à-dire une adaptation du
droit européen comme il existe ce qu'on pu faire
les Britanniques ce qu'on fait les Néerlandais
dans certains sujets en particulier en terme de
taxation ce que font d'autres pays les Danois
par exemple qui ont exercé un tel système sur des
politiques migratoires sur certains sujets et donc
c'est quelque chose qui existe qui n'a pas été mis
en France mais vous savez il faut que la France
impose un peu plus sa place dans le concert des
nations de l'Union européenne moi je me souviens
que quand les intérêts vitaux de la France é était
en jeu au niveau de l'Union européenne le général
de Goul avait fait la politique de la chaise vide
en 1965 pendant 6 mois ça avait cert bloqué les
institutions mais au final on avait un préservver
le budget de la politique agricole commune de
maintenu le droit de vetto sur les sujets les plus
importants on voit bien que quand on va au bras
de fer il est possible de pouvoir remporter des
sujets il y faut pas avoir une destinée qui soit
créée par les juges européens qu'on reprenne de
la souveraineté d'une part aux état d'autre part
au peuple c'est au peuple de décider et non pas à
des gens qui ne sont pas élus alors quand même on
n'y est pas pour pouvoir changer la Constitution
il faut il y a la procédure est lourde il faut
que les deux chambres assemblée Sénat votent
dans le même terme vous croyez vraiment que
ça peut aboutir oui ça peut aboutir et on vous
parliez de la constitutionnalisation du droit
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse euh
bon même c'est un sujet qui en fait ne fait
pas de débat en France c'est un sujet sociétal un
porté des États-Unis aujourd'hui il y a pas une
seule formation politique représenté à l'Assemblée
nationale qui est contre l'interruption volontaire
de grossess vé à l'assemée nationté voté à
l'Assemblée nationale mais on a trouvé un
compromis avec le Sénat la formulation qui est
celle de Philippe Bas au Sénat qui était de dire
de de la liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse c'est quelque chose qui permettait de
sécuriser juridiquement le texte permettait
d'avoir un accord entre les républicains ici
à l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat donc on
voit qu'en travaillant main dans la main côte
à côte il est possible de pouvoir trouver
des formulations parce qu'il faut être très
précis dans la formulation de la réforme de la
Constitution parce que il y a après des questions
d'interprétation de la Constitution qui est celle
du Conseil constitionnel et du juge administratif
et donc ça nécessite d'être extrêmement précis on
peut pas aller à la Vavie donc ce sera en effet
un travail d'écriture extrêmement important mais
j'ai toute confiance dans nos collègues sénateurs
et puis ici mes collègues députés pour trouver
les meilleures formulations qui laissent pas
d'interprétation et pas de possibilité pour les
juges de tordre le coup et le doigt du législateur
qui a écrit la réforme de la Constitution donc
pour vous il peut y avoir un consensus sur cette
inscription du droit à l'IVG dans la constition
je vous dis ça dépendra de la réforme du package
qui sera présenté parce qu'il y a plusieurs
sujets qui ont été ouverts par le Président
de la République va pas faire sujet par sujet
ce sera un ensemble nous nous sommes évidemment
favorable à la formulation que je viens de vous
exprimer qui était celle qui a été présentée par
le Sénat d' alors l'élargissement du champ du
référendum c'est une demande de longue date du
rassemblement national et justement on va écouter
la réaction de Marine Le Pen à ses annonces cette
semaine du président de la République oui notre
Constitution est remarquable il faut donc la
préserver la protéger peut-être d'ailleurs la reli
de temps en temps quand on est dirigeant parce que
on s'aperçoit que petit à petit on l'a un petit
peu vidé de cette puissance mais elle peut-être
améliorée et notamment par la mise en œuvre du
référendum d'initiative populaire qui est absent
aujourd'hui je pense aussi que la Constitution ne
devrait pouvoir être réformée que par référendum
alors justement parlons du référendum d'initiative
partagée entre les parlementaires et les des
citoyens Emmanuel Macron souhaite faciliter le
recours à ce type de référendum d'ailleurs il en
avait déjà parlé après la crise des gilets jaunes
en 2019 mais sans véritable concrétisation et l'an
dernier et bien le gouvernement n'était
pas favorable à un RIP sur la réforme des
retraites est-ce qu'il y a un double discours du
président sur cette question du Rip ce qui est
sûr c'est que ça a bien arrangé le président de
la République qu' ait pas de référendum sur les
retraites ça c'est évident ceci étant dit il faut
que on fixe un cadre qui soit un cadre général et
qu'on l'adapte pas par rapport aux événements que
on puisse développer le référendum d'initiativ
partagé c'est-à-dire abaisser le seuil du nombre
de signataires nécessaires au niveau des citoyens
par exemple passer de 4 à 1 million le seuil c'est
quelque chose qui serait extrêmement positif le
rip qui a été celui qui a été le plus rcontré le
plus de succès c'est celui sur Aéroport de Paris
sur la privatisation d'Aéroport de Paris mais
qui avait obtenu plus d'un million de signatures
et donc c'est quelque chose qui va à mon à mon
avis dans le bon sens là vous faisiez partie des
députés qu'on a qualifié de front ur contre la
réforme des retraites vous regrettez qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de RIP de référendum sur la réforme des
retraites j'ai pas regrettter qu'il ait pas eu de
RIP enin pardon mais le sujet maintenant c'est le
sujet de la Constitution et ça dépasse puisqu'on
parle de loi fondamentale ça dépasse les petite
loi don celle de la retraite qui impacte des
millions de Français certes mais on parle ici de
la réforme de la Constitution il ne s'agit pas de
faire une réforme de la Constitution pour répondre
à tel ou tel besoin c'est ce que j'exprimais sur
la question de l'IVG qui est un débat importé
des États-Unis mais il s'agit en fait de fixer
un cadre qui permettra à de régler l'ensemble
des problèmes s'il y a un nombre minimum de
signatures via le rip ou si en élargissant le champ
du référendum de l'article 11 il y a un sujet que
nous désirons à l'Assemblée nationale et ou au
Sénat être tranché par les citoyens qu'on puisse
le faire on va parler du sujet des punaises de
lit qui s'est invité cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est nuisible disparu dans les années
50 mais qui sont revenus semer la panique
dans le quotidien des Français le gouvernement a
été interpellé à plusieurs reprises sur ce sujet
notamment par la présidente du groupe la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale Mathilde Panau
qui a reproché à la Premier ministre son inaction
ces petits insectes répandent le désespoir dans
notre pays faut-il attendre que Matignon
soit infester pour qu'enfin vous réagissiez
oui les punaises de lit sont une angoisse pour
nos concitoyens qui craignent d'y être confronté
c'est un véritable calvaire pour ceux qui sont
touchés l'infestation d'un logement peut devenir
un enfer pour celles et ceux qui y habitent et
les solutions pour s'en débarrasser peuvent être
coûteuses et la majorité présidentiel a engagé un
travail pour trouver des réponses de long terme
sur la détection l'infestation et l'accompagnement
des personnes touché une réflexion qui devrait
pouvoir rassembler largement dans cet hémicycle
alors travaillons ensemble trouvons des solutions
ensemble Pierre-Henry Dumont est-ce que pour
vous le gouvernement a sous-estimé la la menace
soudain des des punaises de lit il faut trancher
ce qui est de l'ordre du réel et de la psychose
déjà parce qu'on a l'impression tous d'avoir
des punaises de lit chez soi depuis que le sujet
monte et est mise en en exerg dans les médias la
réalité c'est qu'il y a souvent eu des punaises de
lit on prend des articles d' y a 5 ou 10 ans on
voit bien qu'il des lycée avait déjà à l'époque
étit fermé pour des raisons d'infestation DEP
comment vous expliquez cette psychose cette le
fait qu'on en parle soudainement déjà il il
y a des aspects techniques hein c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des insecticides qui ont été interdits
il y a quelques années ensuite on sait bien que
funess de lit voyage avec l'augmentation
des mobilités des migrations que ce soit
celle de voyageurs en particulier et que donc
du coup avec l'interdiction de l'insecticide
en question puis la période covid qui a bloqué
la plupart des voyages on n' pas pu voir les
effets de l'interdiction de cet insecticide sur la
prolifération des punaises de lit avant 2022 2023
c'est-à-dire qu'on est qu'on est aujourd'hui
en plein dedans donc il a avant toute chose
un travail de cartographie des endroits où il
y a le plus de tunaises de lit il y a ensuite
une question de de prévention c'est le point le
plus important c'està dire faire comprendre parce
que c'est un phénomène nouveau puisqueil y a une
prolifération extrêmement importante dans certains
endroits bah que quand on achète des vêtements de
seconde main il faut vérifier que quand on voyage
dans les transports collectifs il faut faire
attention que il y a des des possibilité de mettre
par exemple des vêtements fragiles au congélateur
d'être un peu technique pour tuer les les punaises
de lit donc voilà c'est une question de prévention
qui n'a pas été faite parce qu'il y avait pas de
voyage à un moment où ça avait été normalement le
pic de l'explosion supposé et ensuite il y a la
question qui est la question de pouvoir répondre
aux attentes la question de je vous dis de voir
les outils pour pouvoir les cartographier et
la question du du coût de la prise en charge
de l'éradication des foyers des punaises de lit
et là je suis pas certain que ça doit passer par
la loi il faut avec les moyens être très agiles
les ARS les préfectures faire en sorte de pouvoir
travailler avec toutes les parties prenantes
pour rapidement éradiquer ce fléo et puis aussi
mettre fin un peu à la psychose vous dis faire la
différence entre ce qui ressort réellement d'une
qui supp alors Pierre Henri Dumont en tout cas
dans ce débat devient politique et d'ailleurs
le président du groupe LR à l'Assemblée national
Olivier marlex a dit que oui il y avait un sujet
sur le lien entre camp de réfugié et Puna de lit
je le cite ne soyons pas tartuf est-ce que c'est
propos vous ont gêné ce qui est sûr je vous l'ai
dit c'est que les punaes de lit prolifèrent en
raison des migrations c'està-dire des déplacements
de population et de la promiscuité c'està-dire que
quand vous avez des espaces clos encombrés dans
les prisons par par exemple on voit qu'il peut y
avoir des des résurgences dans des appartements
qui sont des petits appartements avec des
personnes qui vivent à 4 5 6 dans une vingtaine de
mètres carrés il y a un facteur plus favorable à
la prolifération et que les populations immigrées
qui arrivent en France de façon régulière ou
irrégulière ont plutôt tendance c'est les chiffres
et c'est les statistiques qui prouvent aller dans
des endroits où les loyers sont plus faibles
parce que c'est là où vivent leur famille leurs
amis les personnes qui viennent de leur pays
et donc ont plutôt tendance à rajouter et à
vivre dans des espaces qui sont des espaces de
forte promiscuit mais donc vous faites un lien
indirect entre assume assumez il y a à mon sens
un lien indirect c'est pas le facteur déterminant
premier le facteur premier c'est évidemment celui
des voyages celui des ceux qui prennent le train
ceux qui prennent les transports en commun de
ceux qui partent à l'étranger ceux qui vont
dans les chambres d'autel qui peuvent ramener il
y a un lien qui existe mais qui sur la question
migratoire mais qui n'est pas le lien direct
essentiel mais est-ce que ça vous a quand même
choqué ces propos de dire il y a un sujetit il y a
il y a un sujet mais c'est pas le sujet principal
je vous ai répondu non alors en tout cas il y a
une question qui se pose notamment sur l'image de
la France à l'internationale on voit que la presse
étrangère s'empare du sujet il peut y avoir des
inquiétudes sur cette image à l'internationale à
10 mois des Jeux Olympiques ah ben c'est évident
parce qu'en plus on est sur un sujet qui fait
les chougraas des commentateurs des imitateurs
vous regardez le tight show de Jimmy Fallon aux
États-Unis qui a caricaturé le président Macron
en roi des punaises de l bon voilà on est sur un
sujet qui est le sujet de la place du rayonnement
de la France à l'internationale avant les Jeux
Olympiques pendant la Coupe du monde de rugby
c'est évidemment une publicité qui n'est pas très
bonne qui aurait pu qui aurait dû être anticipée
par le gouvernement et qui n'a pas écouté les
alertes qui avaiit été lancé par différents
groupes politiques dont le nôtre alors on va se
projeter sur la semaine prochaine très rapidement
à l'Assemblée nationale le 12 octobre prochain
les députés RN vont porter dans l'hémicycle
une proposition de loi qui prévoit notamment
de suspendre des allocations familiales pour
les parents d'enfants délinquants ou criminels
est-ce que vous députés LR vous êtes prêt à voter
ce texte évid nous allons voter pour une raison
qui est très simple vous l'assumez de voter on
va le voter pour une raison qui est très simple
parce que c'est notre texte ils ont copierécollé
quasiment la proposition de loi de Jean-Louis
Thierot qui est députés les républicains ils ont
repris le principe d'une proposition de loi qui
avait été adoptée mise en œuvre par Eric Ciotti
qui était la suspension des allocations familiales
des parents des enfants absentéistes à l'école et
donc là on est sur la question des la suspension
des allocations familiales pour les parents des
enfants délinquants je vous dis ça a été présenté
par Jean-Lou cot lors d'une proposition de loi il
y a plusieurs mois ils ont repris le stylo en
adoptant un pe en l' adaptant un petit peu nous
aurons des amendements pour revenir à la version
originale qui était présentée par les députés les
républicains mais ce serait complètement idiot de
ne pas voter un texte qui a été écrit d'abord par
les députés et les républicains sous prétexte
qu'il a été repris par tel ou tel groupe merci
beaucoup Pierre-Henri duond c'est la fin de cette
émission merci d'avoir été notre invité merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi et on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine très bonne suite de
programme